most people are useless  in the world they're they're useless  they have to be told what to do every  day they got told be told when to wake  up  uh they're gonna be told one time to go  to Street uh sleep what type of your  sports team is playing uh what to do at  work on a daily basis most people need  guidance on a daily basis uh in essence  you're useless so in essence then if  you're if you're useless I gotta tell  you what to do and how to make love and  and how to treat a woman and all that  stuff you know the guys your guys you  went to high school with that boned all  the hot cheerleaders and the chicks that  guy right there he's been living in this  truth  he's discovered a truth that men don't  discover until age 30 and 40 if at all  that all women are the same